WE HAVE JUST LEARNED JOE BIDEN
HAS BEEN -- TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVID-19.
LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO JEREMY
DIAMOND AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
HOW IS THE PRESIDENT'S HEALTH
OVERALL?
OBVIOUSLY, HE'S FULLY
VACCINATED, BOOSTED.
BUT HE DID JUST COME OFF THIS
BIG OVERSEAS TRIP.
>> Reporter: YEAH, LISTEN.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
SIGNIFICANT NEWS, BUT ALSO VERY
DIFFERENT FROM WHEN WE HAD A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
LAST TEST POSITIVE FOR COVID,
THAT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP BEFORE
HE HAD BEEN VACCINATED.
IN THIS CASE, JOE BIDEN IS
VACCINATED AND DOUBLE BOOSTED.
BUT HE IS EXPERIENCING, WE'RE
TOLD, VERY MILD SYMPTOMS,
ACCORDING TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND HE HAS BEGUN TAKING A COURSE
OF THAT ANTI-VIRAL PAXLOVID
TREATMENT.
LET ME READ YOU PART OF THIS
STATEMENT WE JUST GOT, SAYING
THAT CONSISTENT WITH CDC
GUIDELINES, HE WILL ISOLATE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO CARRY OUT ALL OF HIS
DUTIES FULLY DURING THAT TIME.
HE'S BEEN IN CONTACT WITH WHITE
HOUSE STAFF BY PHONE THIS
MORNING, AND HE'LL PARTICIPATE
IN HIS PLANNED MEETINGS FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, VIA PHONE AND ZOOM
FROM THE RESIDENCE.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THAT
CONSISTENT WITH PROTOCOL, HE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK IN ISOLATION
UNTIL HE TESTS NEGATIVE.
AND ONCE HE TESTS NEGATIVE,
HE'LL RETURN TO IN-PERSON WORK.
THE WHITE HOUSE DID TELL US JUST
YESTERDAY, I BELIEVE, OR PERHAPS
IT WAS THE DAY BEFORE, THAT JOE
BIDEN HAD TESTED NEGATIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
SO HE HAS BEEN GETTING REGULARLY
TESTED, INCLUDING AS HE RETURNED
FROM THAT OVERSEAS TRIP TO
ISRAEL AND SAUDI ARABIA.
NOW JOE BIDEN HAS, FOR THE FIRST
TIME, TESTED POSITIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
HE'S EXPERIENCING VERY MILD
SYMPTOMS ACCORDING TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
AND HE'S NOW UNDERGOING A COURSE
OF THAT PAXLOVID TREATMENT,
WHICH IS CONSIDERED THE GOLD
STANDARD IN CORONAVIRUS
TREATMENT.
SO SIGNIFICANT NEWS, JOE BIDEN,
AGE 79, TESTING POSITIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
>> JER MY DIAMOND, HAS THE WHITE
HOUSE PROVIDED ANY MORE DETAILS
ON WHAT "VERY MILD SYMPTOMS"
ARE?
>> I'M READING THIS STATEMENT
WITH YOU GUYS RIGHT NOW.
IT LOOKS LIKE ALL THEY'RE SAYING
IS VERY MILD SYMPTOMS.
THEY DID NOT DESCRIBE THOSE
SYMPTOMS.
BUT CLEARLY THEY'RE TRYING TO
INDICATE THAT JOE BIDEN IS WELL
ENOUGH TO CONTINUE WORKING FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
AGAIN, IN ISOLATION, AT THE
RESIDENCE OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
NOT IN THE WEST WING ALONGSIDE
STAFF.
AND LISTEN, IT'S NOTABLE THAT IT
HAS TAKEN THIS LONG, FRANKLY,
FOR JOE BIDEN TO GET COVID.
SO MANY AMERICANS HAVE ALREADY
GOTTEN THIS VIRUS.
BUT THE PROTOCOLS HAVE BEEN VERY
STRICT.
EVERY MEETING THAT JOE BIDEN HAS
HAD WITH AIDES IN THE OVAL
OFFICE, PEOPLE WEAR MASKS, THEY
WEAR N-95 MASKS WHEN THEY ARE
AROUND HIM.
BUT WE KNOW THAT HE'S BEEN
INCREASING HIS PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENTS IN RECENT MONTHS.
I WAS WITH HIM IN CLEVELAND A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO WHERE HE
WAS ON A SELFIE LINE TAKING
PICTURES WITH FOLKS, HUGGING,
HAND SHAKES, SOMETIMES KISSING
FOLKS.
SO OBVIOUSLY, HIS EXPOSURE HAS
INCREASED IN RECENT MONTHS, AS
IT DID DURING THAT OVERSEAS TRIP
LAST WEEK TO ISRAEL AND SAUDI
ARABIA.
>> JEREMY, JUST LOOKING AT THE
END OF THIS STATEMENT THAT
YOU'RE READING FROM THE PRESS
SECRETARY, THE LAST SENTENCE
SAYS THE PRESIDENT LAST TESTED
FOR COVID TUESDAY.
HIS PREVIOUS TEST WAS TUESDAY
WHEN HE HAD A NEGATIVE RESULT.
WE JUST SHOWED VIDEO FROM
YESTERDAY, FROM WEDNESDAY.
YOU SEE HIM THERE WITH JOHN
KERRY AND OTHERS.
SO ARE ALL THOSE IN CONTACT WITH
THE PRESIDENT TESTED REGULARLY?
>> Reporter: YEAH, SO ANYBODY
THAT NEEDS TO MEET WITH THE
PRESIDENT INDOORS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS TESTED BEFORE HAND FOR
COVID.
IT'S USUALLY A RAPID TEST THAT'S
PERFORMED AND PERFORMED ON
MEMBERS OF THE PRESS WHO ARE
TRAVELING WITH THE PRESIDENT IN
THE PRESS POOL.
THOSE 13 REPORTERS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS WHO TRAVEL VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THOSE FOLKS ARE ALWAYS TESTED
WITH A RAPID TEST ON THE DAY
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE IN
CONTACT OR TRAVELING WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
I PRESUME THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
WILL BE DOING CONTACT TRACING
AROUND THOSE OFFICIALS WHO ARE
WITH HIM.
SOME OF THOSE MEMBERS WHO
TRAVELED AND FLEW WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON AIR FORCE ONE,
AGAIN, AIR FORCE ONE IS ALSO
STILL REQUIRING MASKS ON BOARD,
EVEN THOUGH THAT FEDERAL TRAVEL
MASK MANDATE HAS FALLEN FOR
COMMERCIAL FLIGHTS.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS INSISTED ON
MAINTAINING MASKS ABOARD AIR
FORCE ONE.
SO OBVIOUSLY, AGAIN, A LOT OF
PROTOCOLS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKING
PLACE.
BUT CLEARLY JOE BIDEN HAS STILL
MANAGED TO GET COVID AT THIS
POINT FOR THE FIRST TIME, OF
COURSE, IN HIS PRESIDENCY AND
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THIS
PANDEMIC.
>> JEREMY DIAMOND, PLEASE STAY
WITH US.
JOINING US NOW, DR. WILLIAM
SHATNER VIA TELEPHONE.
THIS IS NOTABLE, BECAUSE THE
COUNTRY HAS BEEN EXPERIENCING
QUITE A SURGE IN COVID CASES, IN
MANY PLACES EVEN EXCEEDING WHERE
IT WAS AT THE PREVIOUS PEAK.
BUT TELL US, WHAT ARE THE RISKS
TO A 79-YEAR-OLD MAN WHO IS
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED TO GET
COVID TODAY?
>> WELL, PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED CAN STILL
GET MILD CASES OF COVID
INFECTION.
THESE NEW VARIANTS PARTICULARLY
THE BA-5 VARIANT CAN INFECT
PEOPLE WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
VACCINATED, OR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HAD PREVIOUS NATURAL INFECTION.
THAT SAID, THE INFECTIONS THEN
ARE GENERALLY RATHER MILD.
THEY DON'T REQUIRE
HOSPITALIZATION.
AND IN ADDITION, PEOPLE WHO ARE
OVER AGE 65 ARE ALSO CANDIDATES
FOR PAXLOVID, THAT ANTI-VIRAL,
WHICH WILL FURTHER REDUCE THE
RISK OF SERIOUS INFECTION.
>> CAN YOU -- THANK YOU FOR
GETTING ON WITH US SO QUICKLY ON
THIS BREAKING NEWS.
CAN YOU ALSO SPEAK TO WHAT IT
MEANS FOR THE PRESIDENT -- I
MEAN, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT VARIANT
HE HAS, LET'S JUST MAKE THAT
CLEAR.
BUT THERE ARE DIFFERENCES WITH
THE NEWEST VARIANTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, AND I JUST WONDER IF
YOU COULD SPEAK TO THAT AND THE
IMPACT IT COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE
ON THE PRESIDENT, AND ALSO HOW
EFFECTIVE PAXLOVID HAS BEEN
AGAINST ALL OF THESE VARIANTS.
>> WELL, IT CONTINUES, POPPY, TO
BE REALLY QUITE EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING THE RISK OF SERIOUS
DISEASE.
NOW, THERE HAVE BEEN PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HAD PAXLOVID RELAPSE.
THAT IS ALTHOUGH PAXLOVID
SUPPRESSES SYMPTOMOLOGY FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME WHILE YOU'RE
TAKING IT, FIVE DAYS, AFTER
THAT, SOME PEOPLE GET A
RECURRENCE OF SOME OF THEIR
SYMPTOMS.
SO WE'LL HAVE TO WATCH THAT.
BUT THE VACCINES, WITH BOOSTING,
IF YOU'RE UP TO DATE, THAT PLUS
PAXLOVID DO PROVIDE STRONG
PROTECTION AGAINST SERIOUS
DISEASE.
YOU CAN BE DISCOMFORTED, TIRED,
HAVE A COUGH, SORE THROAT, RUNNY
NOSE, AND FEEL RATHER PUNY FOR
SEVERAL DAYS, THAT'S FOR SURE.
BUT THAT CAN BE MANAGED.
OF COURSE, THAT WOULD INTERFERE
WITH THE PRESIDENT'S SCHEDULE IN
A NOTEWORTHY FASHION.
>> DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, ONE OF
THOSE WHO HAD THAT KIND OF
PAXLOVID -- POST PAXLOVID
RECURRENCE HERE.
BEYOND THAT, THE PRESIDENT IS
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED.
THE DATA SHOWS THOSE WHO ARE
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED HAVE A
LESS CHANCE OF SEVERE ILLNESS
AND DEATH.
BUT OLDER PEOPLE FACE GREATER
RISK THAN YOUNGER PEOPLE.
AS A DOCTOR, IF YOU ARE SPEAKING
TO THE PRESIDENT NOW, WHAT WOULD
YOU LEVEL OF CONCERN BE, AND
WHAT ADVICE WOULD YOU GIVE HIM?
>> WELL, OF COURSE WE WOULD ALL
BE CONCERNED.
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
DETAILS OF HIS MEDICAL HISTORY,
BUT I THINK I WOULD BE
CONSIDERING SERIOUSLY PAXLOVID,
GETTING IT STARTED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
WE WOULD COUNSEL THAT HE TAKE
SOME TIME OFF.
MAKE SURE HIS HYDRATION IS GOOD.
WE WOULD WATCH HIM CAREFULLY.
HE MAY WELL DEVELOP A COUGH, AND
WE WOULD WANT TO BE SURE THAT
DOES NOT EVOLVE INTO SOME SORT
OF PNEUMONIA RELATED ILLNESS.
WE THINK THAT WON'T HAPPEN,
BECAUSE AS YOU WERE SAYING, JIM,
THE VACCINES, PLUS PAXLOVID,
REALLY PROVIDE VERY GOOD
PROTECTION AGAINST SEVERE
DISEASE.
AND I WOULD HOPE AND ANTICIPATE
THAT WOULD BE THE CASE IN THIS
INSTANCE ALSO.
>> DOCTOR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STAND BY AS WE BRING IN OUR
SENIOR MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT
ELIZ
ELIZABETH COHEN, AS WELL.
ELIZABETH, AS JEREMY WAS SAYING,
IT'S REMARKABLE ACTUALLY -- IT'S
GOOD TO HEAR THE PRESIDENT HAS
MILD SYMPTOMS, BUT IT IS
REMARKABLE THROUGHOUT HIS
PRESIDENCY, WITH ALL OF THE
TRAVELS HE HAS DONE AND ALL OF
THE INTERACTS, HE HASN'T HAD IT
UNTIL NOW.
AND IT'S GREAT THAT HE'S FULLY
VACCINATED, DOUBLE BOOSTED AND
PAXLOVI IS AVAILABLE.
SO ALL THINGS WORKING IN HIS
FAVOR IS WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
AT.
>> ANOTHER THING THAT'S WORKING
IN HIS FAVOR, HIS SECOND
BOOSTER, SO HIS FOURTH SHOT, WAS
REALLY QUITE RECENT.
IT WAS AT THE VERY END OF MARCH.
THAT MEANS A LOT, BECAUSE WE
KNOW THESE VACCINES ARE SO
POWERFUL, BUT THEY DO WANE WHEN
YOU GET PAST THE, YOU KNOW,
AROUND THE SIX-MONTH MARK.
SO THE FACT THAT IT WAS REALLY
QUITE RECENT, THAT FOURTH SHOT,
THAT MEANS A LOT.
AND POPPY, I WAS THINKING THE
SAME THING YOU WERE THINKING,
IT'S AMAZING IT TOOK THIS LONG
GIVING HOW MUCH THE MAN TRAVELS.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE TO REMEMBER IS
THAT BA-5 IS SO INCREDIBLY
TRANSMISSIBLE.
I REALLY HAVE A HARD TIME
THINKING OF PEOPLE, JUST IN MY
OWN FAMILY OF CLOSE FRIENDS WHO
HAVE NOT HAD COVID.
SO NOT SHOCKING IN A WAY THAT HE
GOT COVID, MAYBE SHOCKING THAT
IT TOOK THIS LONG.